there's a genre of sci-fi that gives us
a glimpse into the future that's totally
different in fact the polar opposite of
the dystopia that we see in cyber Punk
and it's called solar Punk it's idyllic
it's sustainable it's
communal and
it's a yogurt
ad in fact unlike cyber Punk there's not
a whole lot of examples of good solar
punk in mass media and the visual
examples seem to be kind of missing the
point when we analyze solar punk from an
architectural and urban planning point
of you we found out just how many
parallels there were to our reality so
solar Punk could this be our
future a portion of this video sponsored
by HP and
Intel this video is probably one of the
best depictions of solar Punk it's a
future where we merge future technology
with ecocentric values and we thrive in
harmony with nature but the more we
learned about the movement we realize
the existence of this video is actually
the antithesis of solar Punk the punk in
both solar Punk and cyber Punk refers to
Rebellion cyber Punk is against an
oppressive techn dystopia and solar Punk
is against consumerism and capitalism
which is leading to the destuction of
the planet the solar is both literal and
metaphorical literally it represents
solar and other renewable energies and
metaphorically it's talking about this
Beacon of light in a dark cyberpunk
world run by corporate interest
beautiful so an ad using these beautiful
solar Punk Aesthetics and using this
utopian Vision to convince people to buy
their product seems very anti-solar Punk
and unlike cyber Punk which is a huge
part of Pop Culture the real solar Punk
seems to only exist in uh CFI novels or
in a really small Niche section of the
internet there are films and video games
out there that fit the solar Punk
aesthetic but they don't quite fit the
true definition of solar Punk when it
comes to the social or cultural aspect
socially it emphasizes Unity a shared
responsibility and harmony between both
nature and fellow humans and the the
combination of these words kind of
immediately make you think of a
cult and why is that
[Music]
SC maybe it's Hollywood who's done a
really good job of glamorizing this idea
of the sexy rugged Rebel with a six-pack
on a motorbike navigating this dark
dystopian world I mean there's nothing
really sexy about Brian goling in a
farmer
market okay that's still pretty hot
let's look at wakanda from Black Panther
it's probably one of the few iconic
solar Punk Visions from Hollywood it's
the most technologically advanced
country in the world but instead of a
city like this it's surrounded by
sweeping valleys and mountains
technically wakanda doesn't qualify as
solar Punk cuz it's a matriarchal
society and it's not really culturally
diverse but there is a beautiful
integration of Technology into the
city's Fabric and at the same time the
entire Society is grounded in Traditions
that's passed down for Generations but I
think the most solar Punk elements of
wakanda actually came from the location
of the Golden City and this abrupt
transition between the city and the
surrounding
landscape if you look at any North
American city the periphery is
surrounded by High highways and suburbs
something like 52% of Americans live in
suburbs suburbs emerged partly because
cities were polluted and dangerous and
weren't really nice living so in the 50s
and 60s as soon as we had this sudden
boom in car ownership people realized
hey I could live in bigger houses with
green space for less money if I just
moved out of the city but studies show
that Suburban dwellers admit up to four
times amount of emission than people
living in urban areas cuz you're
dependent on cars there's longer
commutes and you're sharing less and
less resources and the creation of a new
suburb often consumes natural habitats
and agricultural lands suburbs also lead
to segregated neighborhoods with very
little cultural or social diversity
which can contribute to a bigger
socioeconomic divide rather than trying
to address the problems in the city we
simply moved our population to the
outskirts and to this day in many parts
of North America suburbs keep growing
it's ironic cuz the idea of a Titanic
community living in open space with
Greenery there is a lot of parallels to
solar Punk ideals in fact both the
design of suburbs and solar Punk were
inspired by the same idea the Garden
City
movement if you want to talk about real
polluted and dirty cities we have to
look at London England during the late
19th century industrialization
completely transformed London into one
of the most slum disgusting unhealthy
places to live in sanitation was
virtually non-existent and the factories
they just dumped everything into the
river which is also where they got their
drinking water cuz the Industrial
Revolution was completely unprecedented
and cities just weren't equipped to
handle the kind of influx of people in
factories this is when Ebenezer Howard
an urban planner from London came up
with this utopian concept for cities
living in nature and called them Garden
cities of Tomorrow a group of Slum
smokeless cities each City or Community
would have a central district that was
dedicated to industry and work from
there you have concentric rings of
housing Gardens agriculture Leisure
space and Civic institutions these
circles were just supposed to be
diagrammatic but I think what's
interesting is that these circular green
belts were a boundary and you could
limit the growth of the population by
Design and when you limit growth you can
also control the density the cost and
the quality of life he even suggested
rough sizes each City would be roughly
6,000 Acres with anywhere between 32,000
to 58,000 people and the city ring would
occupy one six of that space leaving the
rest to Green Space these experimental
Garden cities started to pop up all over
America and the UK but very few actually
became successful cuz while it had the
look of a Garden City it lacked a lot of
the other characteristics like an
industry food production Civic
institutions meaning people would still
need to take their cars and drive to get
to these places which in turn created
suburbs but before we continue a message
from our sponsor HP and Intel I'm always
on the go so the ideal laptop for me is
portable and lightweight a 14-in laptop
can adapt to every situation and I want
as many options as possible when it
comes to Ports like a full-size HDMI
port and a usba but even if this laptop
is Tiny it doesn't mean that you can't
use Rhino and other apps at the same
time the HP elitebook 1040 can be
equipped with up to 64 GB of RAM and
this version has a 13 generation Intel
processor with 14 cores HP and Intel
came together and developed an exclusive
feature called HP Smart Sense which
provides scalable performance that
allows High processing power within a
design that stays light cool and quiet
the HP presence app offers some really
great feature for virtual conferencing
like connecting multiple cameras at the
same time in this case I'm using my
second camera to frame the top of my
desk and the Keystone feature
automatically reframes The View based on
the size of your document with auto
camera select AI recognizes the camera
that I'm looking at so I never have to
break eye contact there's lots of other
features that I really like about this
laptop like the physical camera shutter
fingerprint scanner and really great
speakers so if you want to know more
about the HP lebook 1040 check the link
in the description but maybe we need to
look outside of North
America
this is all mere in fland Netherlands
which was also inspired by The Garden
City movement and according to an
article in blue Labyrinth could be
considered the very first real world
solar Punk city alir is only possible
thanks to Modern engineering they
literally brought a submerged piece of
land back from the sea the whole reason
behind creating alir is to prevent the
growing population of Amsterdam and the
ranan area from expanding into the
designated green areas and like the
Garden City diagram it's a number of
semi-arc each with its own neighborhoods
facilities and identity connected
through a shared infrastructure and a
city center different neighborhoods have
distinct identities from colorful R and
bookboard to the diverse home Rus rotier
with over a thousand southb homes the
districts are separated by water and
parks and Woodlands or agricultural land
where they produce food and apparently
alir has over 100% more green space per
inhabitant than any other Dutch city of
a similar size it's the newest City in
the Netherlands and yet it's considered
the most successful New Town it's only a
few decades old but it's become
Netherlands eighth most populated city
in a lot of ways alir sounds like the
perfect implementation of Garden City
and solar Punk ideals
but when you look closely you start to
notice behind the sustainable facade
it's also subject to the same economic
realities as any other City cuz to build
a successful City for it to scale from a
village to a city of thousands of people
you need capital capital for
infrastructure for governments for
administration the locally grown food
might not be enough to sustain this
larger population so maybe you have to
transport food from other places with a
bigger population there's probably going
to be more waste and pollution even if
it's designed with sustainable
principles which again requires more
money to manage so most cities are
designed and made possible within this
capitalistic framework zoning
regulations and even the layout of a
city grid allows us to expand more
efficiently compared to a more organic
mix use layout which is harder to plan
and it's just hard to please everyone
the scale is usually Way Beyond human
scale cuz in order to maximize profit
you need to maximize the size of your
building often at the expense of green
spaces or Community spaces many public
spaces are actually privatized which can
limit access to certain people even
actual public spaces like Time Square
can be taken over by private interest
very quickly through marketing even
things like Transportation networks are
designed to support areas with high
economic activity or potential for
growth and of course the thing that
drives everything is land value and so
you have one party whose only interest
is driving up the value of their
properties but that's also where people
live so there's kind of a inherent
conflict there essentially cities have
very little to do with the collective
good that solar Punk talks about and a
lot to do with individual or corporate
wealth and here we are again the
foundations of cyber
Punk so what if instead of trying to
force fit solar Punk into our existing
idea of cities we start from the ground
up this is our de huisin again in the
Netherlands it's a commune of 70 people
who organized themselves into
aooc meaning they make decisions through
discussions and team consensus rather
than voting they also grow their own
food they share responsibilities and
they even build their own homes using
mostly recycled reused and locally
sourced building materials like tires
filled with rammed Earth 70% of their
electricity and 100% of their heating is
generated on site and they minimize
energy intake with passive strategies so
from a social and organizational
perspective this is pretty solar Punk
and it's not like there's a size
requirement for solar Punk and it could
definitely be a lowdensity settlement
like this ardois grew out of the Earth
Ship movement from the late 20th century
the earliest Community was built in New
Mexico and it spread to small pockets of
communities around the world and since
they're built by the local communities
with local materials and sight specific
strategies there's a pretty big
diversity in the designs but that just
might be the problem okay when you think
cyberpunk what's the first thing that
comes to your
mind brutalism has always been a pretty
polarizing architectural style a lot of
people absolutely hate these concrete
monsters but it turns out when you put
them in the context of a bleak dystopian
future they actually have a certain kind
of Allure so much so that they become
kind of emblematic of cyber
Punk and this lack of a common
architectural language in solar Punk
might seem trivial but architecture can
often serve as the glue that binds
social movements or a cultural ethos or
as M vandero said it is the will of an
Epoch translated into space for example
the bow house movement was born as a
response to World War I it symbolize a
vision of a new modern Europe it
emphasized functionality and simplicity
and it said no to unnecessary ornaments
it was so culturally transformative that
the principle extended Beyond
architecture from art to furniture and
textiles and I think it really brought
people together solar Punk right now has
a common aesthetic but it's not really
rooted in anything solid that our
culture can grasp so it's hard for us to
imagine it really existing in our real
ity 3 2 1 in the last few years we've
made some pretty big leaps in energy
storage in electric transportation we
have Net Zero buildings and also pretty
efficient systems for food production
but if we are aiming for a true solar
Punk society and not the pretty solar
Punk renderings that we see on Pinterest
the society outlined by these dieh hard
solar Punk fans
then there is a lot of economic
structural social and Architectural
challenges that we'd have to overcome
but maybe it's just this kind of
thinking that's the problem we've looked
at a lot of cyberpunk themes on this
channel and I think it's tapping into
this Collective pessimism that a lot of
us share okay I'm not saying that there
aren't a lot of indications that we're
headed towards this dystopian future
there are but we are kind of conditioned
to expect the worst neuroscientific
Research into defensive pessimism tell
us that pessimism can actually reduce
anxiety especially when the outcome
still has the possibility to be
prevented and this is partly cuz the
brain is predisposed to react more
quickly and readily to negative stimuli
compared to positive ones I think one of
the reasons cyberpunk wins out is cuz
being a pessimist
is
easier I remember taking this class on
sustainability in University and just
being completely and totally depressed
cuz it just seemed like wherever humans
go ecological Devastation inevitably
follows and this is the common rhetoric
and as we get older I think we start to
believe in this idea more and more we
start believing it's always been this
way so it's probably going to be this
way in the future the thing that I like
the most about solar Punk is the
complete blatant rejection of this idea
that humans can exist and Thrive with
nature and technology and that a
beautiful glowing sustainable future is
possible it's solution oriented rather
than dwelling on the problems it's the
harder thing to do and maybe that's what
makes it worth
it
thanks for watching guys which team are
you on cyberpunk or solar Punk let me
know in the comments below also we have
a newsletter and a Discord server we'll
leave the links in the description and
with that I'll see you guys in the next
video
[Music]